hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round seven of
the 2021 sing field cup it's shakti or
mamidara versus fabiano caruana it's a
very very interesting game and uh here
mamidarov tries an opening that fabio
already had with the white pieces but
there's a little bit of a twist to the
game so without further ado let's check
it out and see
how the game went so mommy there are
with the white pieces opens with d4
sorry about that
we have knight to f6 by fabi uh c for e6
uh knight to c3 and bishop to b4 that's
not a bishop we have the names of which
uh the the names of indian defense and
now f3 the more variation uh white ready
to grab the full center with e4 we have
c5 striking in the center here and d5
advancing that pawn uh while getting
ready to push that e4 pawn so d6 by fabi
and e4 now and now uh usually uh black
will just castle here that's the
mostly played move here but b5 is
getting a lot of attention and this is
now becoming more and more popular uh
point is if you capture on b5 then you
no longer defended the d5 pawn with your
c pawn so black can simply open up the
center the knight can't move and if
captures you're going to castle and well
your king is still in the center of the
board could be a little bit dangerous so
instead after b5 we have bishop to d2
now the knight can move and here fabi
just uh removes it from the board bishop
captures we have bishop captures and now
b4
uh grabbing more space on the queen side
attacking this dark square bishop bishop
back to d2 and now fabi castles and the
mamidjarov goes for knight eat knight to
e2 and now we mentioned that um there is
a game that five played in he played it
uh in 2020 almost uh yeah in 2020 in
norway chess he played against levon
arun
and in this position knight the h5 was
played by lavon uh and he was able to
win that game but here uh we have e
capture sunday five and it is not as of
move ten that we have a completely new
game so fabio deviates from uh his game
against levon uh we have e capture
sunday five and now knight the h5 uh so
here the white king is still in the
center of the board and uh mamadourov uh
tackles this by playing king to f2 later
on you're gonna play knight to f4
hopefully trade off the the pair of
knights get the bishop into the game and
then maybe play rook to e1 and you will
have finished development so f5 fabi
with some ideas of maybe even playing f4
if that pawn comes to f4 then white will
have a very hard time developing so
knight to f4 and uh fobby trades we have
knight captures bishop captures and now
g5 and now the problem is this bishop
does not have all that many squares of
course you can't go here we're just
going to trap it with f4 and the the
spawn chain here is really making it a
problem for this bishop to be of any use
so bishop back to c1 yeah you could also
play bishop to d2 but it's still not uh
not another great piece
probably bishop to c1 then he wants to
play b3 and then bishop to b2 and here
is going to be a great piece that's why
playing the seemingly more inactive move
instead of bishop to d2 but okay bishop
to c1
and now you could grab even more space
with with f4 but fabi simply continues
developing knight to d7 uh and not f4
mahmoud doesn't want to allow fabi to
push f4 himself with knight to f6 and
now king to g1 so getting the king to a
bit of a safer square but it's um
i mean uh mamadirov is up material but
his rook is stuck on h1 and until he can
get that rook into the game it's going
to be very hard for him to play this so
knights the e4 by fabi uh and namadar
would be very happy to trade off some
material f captures on g5 he definitely
wouldn't mind knight captures uh and
then let's say bishop captures but uh
fabi just continues with f4
so he gives up a little bit of material
uh further uh to uh start an attack on
mahmoud's king with bishop to d3 now
that the pawn move this bishop can grab
more space here the knight is attacked
with queen to e7 defending the knight
and queen to e2 attacking the knight
twice bishop to f5 fabi develops by
defending the knight here and now bishop
captures an f4 the uh by developing the
bishop here the rook is no longer
guarding the f4 pawn so bishop captures
on f4 and now comes queen to g7
and it's a it's a really tricky position
uh because white is up two pawns but uh
white still has to get his rook into the
game and here it's a question how do you
continue playing this uh the thing is
you could go for bishop captures an e4
and this seems to be the the best idea
the problem is after bishop captures you
can't capture here you have to go bishop
back to g3 and then it's a really really
weird position where white should be
better but your rook is still on h1 if
you can somehow properly get this rook
into the game then you will be better
the problem is if you capture the bishop
here then you get rook a to e8 and now
these rooks are just monsters here queen
to f3 you have to keep an eye on your
bishop just queen to d4 check and you're
gonna win back your piece so it's
another problem uh so he doesn't like
that uh going straight for bishop
captures on e4 so he plays rook to f1
but now we have bishop to g6
we have h3 now
making some room along those dark dark
squares for the bishop but also maybe at
some point maybe king to h2 can be
played we have rook eight to e8 and now
queen back to c2 now you want to move
the queen away from the the rook on the
e file so queen to c2 and now queen to
d4 with check we have king to h2 and now
rook to f7 fabi with some ideas of
doubling up on uh the e or the f file
all depending on what white plays uh and
here we have queen to e2
and this is another moment where you
have to thread very carefully uh you
could go for bishop captures on e4 and
after bishop captures an e4 queen to e2
you pin the bishop as the rookier is
undefended and now let's say black
offers a queen trade we're going to
trade here play rook f2 and now white
can finally get his rook into the game
and well
he should be able to to uh just continue
playing this game
but mamidarov decided to play queen to
e2 yes the knight is still pinned the
rook uh i would be hanging on e8 but now
uh there is a one move that fabi can
play and that is knight to f6 now the
knight covers the rook the rook attacks
the queen and you have to move the queen
and here mamidorov moves it to d1
although this is uh hardly the best
square for the queen the best square is
queen to f2 but this is a very
complicated line uh which i will show uh
just for your viewing pleasure so queen
to f2 is what should have been played
and now we get the the following tricky
line bishop captures on d3 uh g captures
on f6 and now bishop captures on f1
grabbing that rook now comes queen to g3
with check uh you can't go to f8 because
bishop to h6 just wins the game so king
the h8 and now we're gonna play rook
captures on f1 and you get this very
tricky position where uh black is up the
exchange but white has this very
dangerous pass pawn on f6 and the point
is after queen captures on f6 we have
this beautiful bishop to e5 move that
allows us to save the game with white um
uh you you can't of course uh move the
queen because the king would be in check
and uh you you can't really play
something like uh d captures on e5 if
you play d captures on e5 uh then rook
captures rook captures and now queen to
h4 you will be in a lot of
a lot of trouble here because you will
not be able to defend the position the
past deep on along with the
discoordinated rooks will be enough for
white to win the game for example rook
f7 we're going to play queen to h5 now
attack the rooks and after king the g7
defending now we can play queen to g5
with check let's say king h8 and now d6
and there's not all that much you can
play here uh if rook the d7 we're going
to play a very nice queen to h5 attack
the rook and now after let's say rook to
e6 going for a double attack here uh
queen to f5 just wins you're either
winning this rook or this rook or if
black really wants to win that pawn uh
well then we just deliver queen to f8 to
checkmate so there are a lot of ways you
can win this uh so point is after this
queen captures on f6 and bishop to e5
black would have to go for the uh well
just for the absolute best rook caltrans
on e5 uh give up the queen this way and
now two rooks against the queen we would
probably see a draw uh somewhere along
these lines but mamadirov doesn't
appreciate this queen to f2 idea uh he
plays queen to d1 and now fabi takes uh
full advantage of this because it's a
very similar position uh but also a very
different one bishop captures on d3 uh
and now not of course not queen capture
g captures on f6 the knight is hanging
there bishop captures an f1 and now
queen to g4 with check king to h8 again
we cannot go to f8 so king to h8 and now
rook captures an f1 and now it's a it's
a similar position to the one that we've
discussed but now rook captures on f6
this can be played and now there is no
bishop to e5 move it simply it does not
exist so here we have rook to f3 trying
to bring that rook into the attack but
now fabi just plays
rook the g8 puts more pressure on the
queen here queen to h4 putting pressure
on the rook here on f6 but now just
queen captures on b2 threatening
checkmate so rook to g3 defending
against checkmate and now rook captures
on g3 with bishop captures on g3 and now
uh mamadirov has this position where uh
it's not easy for for black to you know
go about this position uh unfortunately
it is uh there's one move that that's
completely winning for fabi so feel free
to pause the video here and win the game
for fabi while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the queen can't really move anywhere
from this diagonal as then well rook
queen captures rook would happen and if
the rook moves anywhere from f6 then we
will be able to harass the black king
and that's not something you want to do
so to everyone who found it
congratulations it is of course queen to
d4
uh and now uh you're still defending
everything you're threatening to pick up
the the white queen and uh well
capturing this is just completely
winning for black there's no point even
trying this end game so of course uh
mamadourov had to avoid this he played
queen to h5 now trying to get some
checks in uh but now fabi covers this
square queen to e4 that prevents the the
queen from delivering any checks we have
queen to g5 attacking the rook here now
queen to g6 fabi simply offers a queen
trade because the the resulting end game
will be winning for him we have queen
back to e3 and now we have queen to f7
so what can you do here we have queen to
b3
but now comes rook to g6 and he was in
this position i know 38 that shocked her
mommy resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh to give
you uh well just a quick example for
example if queen b2 check we can simply
play queen here we block check and
threaten to
win the bishop here so the the endgame
is completely winning we have to try and
guard the the bishop here but now we
just play a5 and a few more pawn pushes
before we trade everything along the g
file and that's it white doesn't really
have a useful move for example bishop f4
a4 and now well let's say for for the
fun of it uh bishop g3 so now we can
trade everything off captures captures
and captures and our passport can easily
win the game here
in case you were wondering how this
might might go it would not be played
this way as these gentlemen are much
much uh
better chess players but they are so
good they don't even have to play it out
uh so there you have 38 moves after rook
g6 mamadou resigned and the fabi almost
joins the leaders but uh our true leader
of the tournament is maxine vashir
lagrave we're not gonna show the
standings just yet as i do have this
rule where i show at least three games
before we check out the standings
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it very nice uh
bounce back by fabi i would like to
thank uh tom derelo balashtanka david
kimura j langdon consulting and joseph
koprechanin for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank all
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
uh sinful cup and uh whatever else
happens in the chess world along with
your wonderful suggestions of course uh
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day